[Música]
karla morales estudió derecho en la
universidad católica de guayaquil
activista y consultora en derechos
humanos trabajó para la comisión
interamericana de derechos humanos en
washington dc fue directora de derechos
humanos para américa latina y el caribe
de la ong francesa asuntos del sur
actualmente es directora ejecutiva de la
de la organización care embajadora de la
organización de raizen y pública pero el
huffington post' y el país
cuando yo era muy pequeña antes de
recibir de mi mamá lecciones de esto
está bien esto está mal ella siempre me
decía antes de buscar me salva te
salvaste tú te dado las herramientas
reacciona rápido salva te y creo que se
salva te ese empuje de ella es mi mejor
herencia y está aquí cuando tenía tres
años
mi mamá perdió a su mamá cuando yo nací
mi papá a su papá cuando yo iba a nacer
mi abuela paterna vive fuera del país y
mi abuelo materno vive en san vicente en
manabí no teníamos un abuelo en casa la
mayoría tenía un abuelo en casa en el
día de los abuelitos nosotros no
teníamos a quien decirle felicidad el
abuelito no lo teníamos a la mano ahora
tenemos una tía que hace las veces de
abuelita
en ese momento cuando tenía tres años un
bisabuelo llego a casa
por problemas de salud
me levanto una madrugada escuchó la
canción del chavo y me perdonan si por
ahí se me quiebra la voz un poquito
escuchó la canción del chavo y quien no
ama el chavo a quien no le gusta el
chavo que me levante
busque la canción del lugar de donde
salía esa canción
llegué al dormitorio donde él estaba
lo vi viendo el show y él hizo este
movimiento
qué significaba que había espacio a su
lado que yo podía ir a dormir acostarme
con él para ver el show me acosté con él
para ver y empecé a ver la serie y al
cabo de unos pocos minutos imaginen a
una persona anciana con vías en las
manos y con una situación de salud
compleja
al cabo de unos minutos empezó a tocarme
empezó a sacarme la ropa a intentar
sacarme la ropa
empezó a forzarme y con la poca fuerza
que tenía me puso sobre él
que creen que recordé
salva t
nadie puede tocar tu cuerpo si tú no
quieres
nadie te puede imponer nada si no nace
de tu voluntad y si no es decisión tuya
tres años me tiré de la cama corría el
cuarto de mi mamá
con el lenguaje que puede tener un niño
tres años le conté lo que había pasado y
esta persona en la que yo confiaba al
mil por ciento me devolvió esa confianza
y salió como decimos siempre como leona
a defender a su cría y bueno la historia
se la podrán imaginar pero que aprendí
en ese momento
que los miedos se enfrentan que la única
forma de crecer es enfrentar el miedo es
ponerle la cara
es hacerle frente a las cosas que nos
incomodan
es ponerle el pecho a la adversidad
y entender que aunque nos duela es
también una oportunidad para aprender
para crecer
y para poderle decir a otro yo pasé por
eso yo te entiendo y creo en ti
que ven ustedes ahí
la mayoría de una ciudad de la una casa
mi casa
yo veo un centro de acopio desde el 16
de abril
allí hay una casa destruida es la casa
de la gata están los voluntarios de cali
conocen esa casa es la casa de la gata
pueden ver una estructura caída después
de un terremoto o pueden ver un centro
comunitario levantado
pueden ver un camión
o pueden ver un aula de clase
la adversidad está ahí
los desafíos los miedos el cuco que nos
dicen cuándo estamos chiquitos está ahí
pero depende de nosotros que vemos
vemos el centro comunitario vemos el
salón de clase
el diccionario de oxford dice que la
resiliencia es la capacidad de las
personas para superar el trauma yo le
agregaría que es la capacidad de las
personas para superar el trauma
y ver una oportunidad en la crisis y
salir adelante pese a cualquier
circunstancia
sobre todo yo creo que la resiliencia es
esa capacidad que tenemos nosotros de
superar los desastres internos de
superar nuestros tsunamis nuestros
terremotos los que están adentro si no
tenemos capacidad de resolver esas
adversidades internas nosotros nunca
vamos a tener la capacidad de ayudar a
alguien a superar las suyas nunca vamos
a poder estar bien con los demás si no
estamos bien con nosotros mismos
nunca vamos a poder decir un te amo real
si nosotros no nos amamos a nosotros
mismos
y así nació todo
todo el movimiento de solidaridad que
nosotros fuimos testigos el 16 de abril
de la ciudadanía ecuatoriana y de los
ecuatorianos que están afuera nació
gracias a una red social que nos
permitió transmitir un mensaje y que
hizo que muchísima gente confiara una en
otra cuando ni siquiera nos conocíamos
pero también esa red social me ha puesto
de frente a una de las adversidades más
difíciles a las que he tenido que poner
cara
a que gente que ni siquiera me conoce me
destruya
día a día
o al menos piensen que me destruye
porque es la capacidad de destrucción
dependerá de cuánto nosotros permitamos
ese año
la resiliencia es precisamente abrazar
esta adversidad esa red social que a mí
me dio la oportunidad de llevar ayuda
hoy me destruye
hoy sin siquiera conocerme
los quiero invitar a que abracen esa
adversidad a que se empoderen del miedo
se empoderen del terror
y aprovechen los frutos que nacen de eso
la adversidad pare como una madre padre
la adversidad pare y pare perseverancia
para disciplina para solidaridad
también puede parir amarguras tristezas
dolor daño pero nosotros tenemos la
capacidad de escoger que pare y
aprovechemos la abracemos la y
disfrutemos de esos frutos que nacen a
partir de esas situaciones de terror y
de miedo como les dije hace un momento
hay que enfrentar el miedo para poder
crecer
si yo me hubiera dejado rendir por la
cantidad de ataques que recibo al día
hubiera dejado de llevar un tarro de
leche anoche hubiera dejado llegar un
contenedor de 40 pies hasta mi casa
es lo importante de nosotros poder
entender que la resiliencia no es
solamente una palabra bonita que está de
moda
es una capacidad innata del ser humano
que nosotros debemos abrazar me gusta
muchísimo este cuadro que lo encontré en
internet y que aprovecho que está la
exposición anterior en la que hablaba de
apropiarnos de la información que está
ahí de democratizar la tecnología la
resiliencia habla de preparación de
transformación de recuperación de
adaptación y de resistencia todo eso lo
tenemos son talentos que cada uno de
nosotros lleva consigo pero que tiene
que descubrir y que potencializar en
razón de cada una de las adversidades
que encuentran
cuando tenía 22 años pensé que me había
sacado la lotería conocí a un abogado me
enamoré
tuve uno de mis noviazgos más largos
afortunadamente terminé como diría mi
esposo
y viví una de las situaciones más
complicadas que se pueden vivir porque
yo creo que nada te enseña más que un
corazón roto muchas veces y
aunque mi mami ahora se ría pero en ese
momento era un shock llegué y le conté
gracias a una incidencia de mi hermana
que había descubierto ese novio con una
chica en la cama literal al mejor estilo
de thalía ahí los dos y yo abrí la
puerta
entonces salí paréntesis recuerden a
mamá enterándose que la hija tenía
llaves del departamento del novio no era
otra situación que tenía que enfrentar
después de pasar es entonces
se para él me sigue hasta la puerta y yo
me quedé ahí como que para dónde cojo yo
no iba en un escándalo no sabía armar un
escándalo usted me diréis él se paró en
la puerta y me dice es lo que hay
olímpicamente es lo que hay por lo que
recibe
y me saqué la lotería porque es una de
las mejores cosas que me puedo pasar en
la vida hay un programa español que se
llama 'el hormiguero' que sacó un vídeo
con artistas que habla de hay que darle
vuelta a la tortilla
ese es lo que hay era mi tortilla
quemada
yo tenía que darle la vuelta
le di la vuelta aprendiendo qué
hay hombres que te rompen el corazón hay
mujeres que sabemos romper el corazón
creo que las mujeres sabemos más que los
hombres rompe el corazón
pero son situaciones que te ayudan a
enfrentar ese miedo a crecer ese miedo a
entender que te fallaron ese miedo a la
traición
es lo que hay es lo que está fuera en el
mundo es lo que nos venden todos los
días son esas ideas de nos reíamos con
inés hace un momento meterle un filtro
es lo que hay eso es lo que te dice el
mundo que una foto se arregla con tres
filtros que un problema se arregla va
viéndolo y que una situación difícil
puede ser ignorada es lo que hay pero
que darle la vuelta a la tortilla
hay que darse cuenta de que hay otras
cosas y la mejor forma de hacerlo es
dejar de hacer lo que nos han
normalizado como comportamiento de todos
lo que nos enseñan en las aulas ver
tragar masticar
mira ve mastica y trata también no
preguntes no desarrollo es pensamiento
crítico no cuestiones yo creo que el
cuestionamiento oxigena y que es
necesario para poder corregir
especialmente pero esto nos enseñan
todos los días yo los invito a que miren
miren y miren
si escuchamos en lugar de oír vamos a
ser capaces de adaptar y transformar
y eso es un talento innato en el ser
humano
enfrentemos el miedo para poder crecer
miremos miremos y miremos cuestionemos y
preguntemos es la única manera de ayudar
a que otro corrija y de nosotros poder
desarrollar un pensamiento muchísimo más
crítico de dejar de simplemente ver
masticar y tragar que es a lo que nos
han enseñado a los gobiernos a las
autoridades a las personas que les
incomoda el cuestionamiento les conviene
que veamos más que creemos y traemos un
pueblo que no pregunta un estudiante que
no cuestiona un hijo que no pide la
palabra
facilita el trabajo de aquel al que no
le conviene corregir de aquel que no
prefiere reconocer que se equivocó y le
hace el camino más fácil al mediocre
turno
para terminar les quiero a través dejar
la pregunta en la mesa
están viendo o están mirando si ven ahí
hay una carpa en un albergue si miran
allí hay un hogar los invito a mirar a
mirar adaptar y transformar muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]